ce bébé dans les bras de madame arafat
zahwa la fille du chef de noël paix et
de soi arafat né à paris il y a deux
mois
elle assistera à la signature des
accords de washington est peut-être
connaîtra-t-elle plus tard l'état
palestinien qui se dessine c'est pour
présenter à jacques chirac le texte des
accords sur l'extension de l'autonomie
palestinienne qu arafat a fait escale à
paris la france 2 chaque année 250
millions de francs à l'autorité
palestinienne
elle est donc partie prenante à l'accord
dont la signature sera suivie de la
libération de plus de 5000 prisonniers
palestiniens et les evènes haythem
grippale est un élément très important
de la cosc la libération des prisonniers
se fait juste après la signature de
l'accord le chef de noël péparation à
washington avec le soutien total de la
france
c'est une paix des braves entre nous et
les israéliens
c'est pour ça que j'utilise le même
terme que le général de gaulle à
utiliser problème jerry 7 pence et
nécessitait beaucoup de courage de part
et d'autre zawa attendu pendant une
heure que son père ait fini ses
entretiens avec le président jacques
chirac avant de quitter paris pour la
première fois avec son père et sa mère
ensemble faire la voix on les après la
fête de washington va commencer
l'épreuve de vérité l'armée israélienne
a dix jours pour se retirer des
principales villes de cisjordanie et
permettre ainsi aux palestiniens
leurs représentants et de gagner un peu
de souveraineté sur la fusion d'amis
occupée